juli ich sehe die höhle mein gott oh
mein gott direkten creeper hier richtig
gemacht
mein gott zurückhaben wasser einmal
mitgenommen da könntest du theoretisch
hoch schwimmen nein ich hab mein stack
cobblestone runtergeschmissen
hallöchen freuen und herzlich willkommen
tsum minecraft captain teil zwei
jahrzehnten zusammen mit komme und wir
wollen jetzt erst mal nach oben gehen
nachdem in der letzten folge hier sehr
viele neue höhlen gänge gefunden haben
kisten gefunden haben ein skelett am
start haben wir auch noch stadt genau
und wir haben da und monster geworden
und ganz ganz viele sachen wir wollen
jetzt erstmal unser sachen seven durch
dieses labyrinth hier eben durchlaufen
da war schon wieder eine wolke bei mir
bei mir auch da unten so als wollte man
man jetzt war man erst mal die sachen zu
helfen und wir können das jetzt auch mit
der kuh machen
diese erhalte da oben töten dann habe
ich wieder 90 tiefen und wir haben auch
schon hier soll noch holzkeil wir haben
ja schon zuckerrohr gefunden nehme auch
die zahlen am besten mit behinderten
oder oder fürs geld und wir haben unten
schon zuckerrohr gefunden das kommt in
zwei -fans können wir das abbauen
wenn wir jetzt die kuh getötet haben
dann nur noch eine tiefe und ich weiß
gar nicht lang laufen muss ich komme mir
hingegen ich glaube ich habe schon sie
am besten aus den höhlen gelten
ich hab ihn ständig alle ist wie meine
linke hosentasche nicht für die rechte
nicht wie die rechte nehme die linke die
einfach die mobs hier weg hat also erst
nichts
lecker schmecker beiden diesen stein
kommen lassen
ich habe abgebaut ich möchte ein
bisschen risiko drin weiß dass er hier
geht's jetzt hoch sind aber echt
komische gänge und jetzt ob der minister
jetzt kommen die monster wider ohne ein
wort ich höre sie ja du läufst genau
muskulär am keeper vorbei
eine fackel ja nie habe ich nicht gut
aber das eisen frei gesprengt sehr
positiv und wir sind nicht gestorben
mensch das ist aber klasse von com ist
ein bisschen roboter aber das ist komme
mal ist er total total der roboter
müssen landverbindung alle farben
versagt ja mein internet ist immer am
versagen
diese tür sie ist einfach sooo gut
also ich gehe jetzt ganz eben ganz kurz
nach oben holen schüsseln am besten mal
alle schüssel mit und für alle auf damit
irgendwie so oft immer nach oben laufen
mache ich habe weiter schlüssel
das ist mit den zahlen vielleicht doch
nicht so eine gute halterung kann er
immer noch so halb runterfallen und
taktieren am besten mal in die
wertvollen tue ich mach das mal so ich
mache ich gleich moment da unten fallen
glaube ich grad sonne hin
ich mache das jetzt mal einfach mit
diesem land hier oben
ob es kaputt gemacht was falsch gelaufen
ich gebe mir mal den bogen mit sich
bringt ja auch mal einen mit und pfeile
sowie ich denn jetzt machen hier um
ich nenne es mal den sand von von wo
kann ich in den sand nehme ich einfach
mal von hier drei sand brauche ich dann
packt den landtag vorne hin dann ist das
dann nämlich auch so ein bisschen
gesichert so gut ich wir brauchen auch
ein tor haben wir schon ein tor bei dem
gehege nähe wurden die noch gar nicht da
aber bei den katzen haben wir 1 hatte
ich mache noch mal eben schnell ein
käufer findet töten
ich bin unterwegs so okay so haben wir
auch wieder lecker lecker schmecker
soweit wir brauchen noch hier sticks
zack zack zack zack jetzt einmal noch
ein tor
ich bringe das tor eben oben an und
danach töte ich ne kuh von solch das tor
macht das einfach mal hier relativ
zentral dabei jedoch stimmt ja macht
dass man kollege noch nicht vor nächstem
warte wir fahren die noch einmal wir
wollen uns auch eine kuh mit dazu
schwimmend einer privaten ich hole
getreide haben wir ja genügend das wäre
ja wohl eher möchte rein aber er kommt
nicht rein durch unsere profite und ich
glaube irgendwie die können der tür auch
kein schaden machen ich weiß ja nie mehr
platz dafür ja ing sein wenn einfach die
mega tür gemacht so warte mal hier
jetzt gibt es ein paar neue kür
salafisten gebiet macht euch schon mal
alle bereit für den humba humba
tanzfreunde als zweitplatzierte erst mal
an wenn ich das vergrößern möchte dann
ja wir können das ja einfach noch ein
bisschen umbau nicht wird erst mal eine
coole macht das kleine ich habe auch
erst mal die schöne liebeslieder to nine
davon kriegt man kein leder nicht euer
chimki kriegt man von der predigt hätte
die einfach mal ein lehrer bekommen dann
brauchen wir noch monument eine kuh
getötet erfolge q2 sammler etwas leder
vielleicht weil ich einfach kein leder
bekommen hat von der ich habe eine
fleisch bekommen obwohl vielleicht
ankara ist ein pilz kuh ist und hat gar
kein leder
ja ich weiß wird das gehege einfach mal
so bauen eben moment ich vergrössern
schön in die richtung hier so ok ist
nein so noch nicht warten einfach an
conny waßmuth ich habe eine richtig gute
idee ist auch okay
die griechen hier ein moment ja moment
machen ganz kurz dann kommt jedoch eben
das sound tor hin so gucken jetzt können
wir ihnen die andere richtung immer
vergrößern
jetzt machen wir noch etwas machen für
ein gehege johann ganz normal ist ne so
sagt er ist reicht es schon viel anfang
ja eigentlich braucht man nämlich auch
keine hühner und so was alles weil wenn
wir die haben dann reicht das ja von
allen leuten jedoch seine vorkammer
einbauen aber nee ist quatsch brauchen
wir gar nicht wenn er mal eine coole
durchläuft da kann man die nämlich in so
einer schleuse abfangen hier habe ich
denke mir mal bitte noch die ranken dann
baue ich war die leiter weiter nach
unten
genau darum hat er noch mehr geben da
sind auch noch welche euro
dann packe ich meine sachen kurzbuch
durch seine crew aus die praktisch nur
ein bisschen raus egal ich sollte mal
ganz kurz eben unten die sache nicht
schon mal ganz jetzt was ich noch
erreichen könnten bis dahin können wir
nicht machen
greenspan brauchen kakteen haben die
lovestory jedoch nicht noch noch nicht
genau ob man den ton rein das
schwarzpulver die knochen pack ich auch
mal daran dass knochen mir mal hier rein
so dazu fressen da brauche ich nicht
da kann man kein richtiger brauchen wir
auch wieder warte mal ich mach ja mach
du mal ein paar fackeln okay
so dann noch hier so 15 also fackel
gemacht 60 fackeln haben wir jetzt
übertreibt nicht
ja dann haben erst mal ein bisschen was
so die fäden kommen in die unwichtige
christensen weiß nicht ob ich erstmal
die wichtige haben bogen das sicher habe
ich dem hingeworfen was so cool sound
ist wichtige eisengitter ist unwichtig
die schere nehme ich mal nicht mit weil
wir haben jetzt erst mal genug davon und
sonst wäre es eventuell sinnvoll ich
nehme immer ein eimer mit und packte
auch wasser rein
jo vielleicht wäre es gut falls
irgendwann mal brennt ich habe hier
fackeln für dich auch da steht zombie
den ganz ich bin hier bei leiter einfach
den gang runter ja da kannst du mir
entgegenkommen hatte ich glaube ich
nehme auch mal steine mit und machte es
da mal komplett zugebaut diesen gang
welchen weil auf diese leiter da also
auf einer seite ist ein bisschen offen
und da könnte man runter fallen immer
bemüht stimmt also man könnte könnte
könnte erteilte fahrt hätte ich aber
natürlich falls welche brauchst er gerne
gern einmal her damit
sodann geht es hier nach unten hier
kommen steine hin aber kein hacker keine
stein hinsetzen stimmt dass er die world
bowl egal so
wir müssen das ganze eigentlich mal so
ein bisschen schönborn roboter sind
schon wieder so viele zombies stärkt
jetzt sterbe in ordnern gott ich sie
später
trotz sehr guter alter wo kommen die
alle her ach so ich geh ja stimmt die
kommen alle diese seiten gänge so
richtig seit längerem ihr doch alle
dicht gemacht da bist du da da oben bin
ich noch so das heißt wir brauchen hier
noch keiner hin
ich habe schon ja spinnen nicht auch
dadurch stärken
da bist du ja auch ein mann als extra
schon seine fackel eingesetzt ja denn
hier waren wir schon mal okay in den tag
genau nicht ganz runter kommen seine
fackel mal runter schmeißen noch nicht
dankeschön mensch kann ich bis heute
wieder aufgesammelt also ich habe 60
stück dann hab ich meiner 30 jahren
angegeben
ja schön ich mal hin
kommandant lange waren die falsche
richtung ich mache den gang offen da
steht einfach eine hexe vom ihr paradies
tod deswegen niemals hin gang auf machen
ich habe zu ihr beiden scheiben geiler
die hat mir zucker gegeben
echt ja dann können wir ja bei den
kuchen machen will dennoch 2 das kann
man noch zucker je ein zocker fehlt
sogar nur noch auf drei glaube ich drei
dann milch und und noch vieles mehr
willi koppmann milch bekommen wir
bekommen wir milch von den kühen oben
ich habe ganz kurz ein bisschen
mache immer mal so eine fackel in die
gänge wow
und es wurde licht ich glaub ich geh mal
in den gang oben runter ich mich jetzt
mal ein bisschen irgendwie mitglieder
mit ihrer kleidung zu stoßen glaube ich
hatte doch nie waren wir schon mal
wo bin ich denn hier ich glaube an
unseren anderen weg man noch mal runter
und schauen was da noch so ist oder was
ich neues aufgetaucht hat jetzt nichts
neues die challenge wäre es schneller
unten
ich suche schon die ganze zeit ob er
noch neues holz ist hier ist keins da
kommt gleich noch was
die welt wurde gespeichert so wie geht's
weiter nach unten
wir sind also quasi auf einer höhe
schneller gommel schneller nein du hast
mich überholt ich falle ja auch gerade
so halt immer runter so warte hier ist
nicht sonderlich was wir brauchen
die kiste hier kommt in zwei schief
münster es kommt hier der neue kiste
archiv in köln ganz kurz wo ich bin
jetzt nicht was wir machen können
läge mit einer nacht in der lohrer haben
wir schon eher stimmten bauer ein
diamant mit hilfe einer ich hätte ja man
wer mal cool diamanten ja ich war
überhaupt kein plan b bei diesen gängen
war doch hier geht es noch weiter runter
ich komme ja gar nicht mehr klar
deswegen haben wir jetzt so ein leiter
garson jahrgang
da kommen schon wir silberfische so auf
deiner höhe ich habe die befürchtung
gestoßen da bald wieder auf einen raum
der das ende herbei bedeute erstmal
wieder ein zombie soll das thema
weiterhin den gang lang
ich habe selber versteht zwei okay tot
all das hat auch scheiß viecher ja die
nerven richtig und die machen viel
schaden
das kommt dann noch hinzu wenn man auf
silberfische stößt die können schnell
mal töten
da ist dieser sport den wir letztens
schon gefunden hatten
ich laufe gar nicht herum er aber wieder
angst vor dem motto ich habe auch gerade
angst dass sich hierunter fallen bei dem
wunderschönen leiter gang bist du denn
natürlich ist wie auf gleicher höhe
yeah jetzt aber auch glaube ich nichts
neues wieder nichts neues die kiste an
die hatten wir schon geöffnet haben aber
nicht mitgenommen die kiste kommt machen
wir das gold gefunden wo bist du denn ja
gold ist wichtig gold sehr sehr wichtig
ich sehe dich nicht gar mehr ich wähle
ich nicht ich bin hier unten
ich betone ich nehme noch weiter wo bist
du denn
ich hab nicht mal wenn ich habe eine
spezielle plattform ihr weg ist das
knuffig ok alter alter alter hilfe
nein nein conny conny thema nicht
genutzte nicht den leiter gang von mir
nutzt ihn nicht wann ich will darunter
ganz wunder gester stützt eine schlucht
ich bin in englisch schlucht gestürzt
haben noch dreieinhalb herzen und rate
mal wie viele monster hier sind traurig
eindeutig ein habe ich hab ich grad
studiert leder namen ich kann mich jetzt
zu dir
nein eben nicht nur vorsichtig dann ganz
vorsichtig sneaker am ende von dem lian
ich bin nicht in die angegangen ich
mache jetzt unseren kleinen weg ich bin
ja fast da alter sind hier viele monster
ich weiß gar nicht wie wir die alle
töten wollen sie zu meinen namen schon
also ich halte es auch der wald muss
aufpassen engmann da geht es richtig
weit runter also ich dachte ich ich bin
ich mir auch schon lange tot aber ich
habe noch glück gehabt
ok ich komme also ich war gerade am gold
abbauen plötzlich fall ich dann diese
hülle rein
ich sehe die hülle mein gott oh mein
gott direkten creeper hier richtig
gemacht
mein gott zum glück habe ich ein wasser
einmal mitgenommen da könntest du
theoretisch hoch schwimmen ich habe mein
stack cobblestone runtergeschmissen nein
hier alleingänger mäßig so alle zu töten
und khaki ist einfach körper vor meiner
nase und
das alte die stehen hier auch alle vorm
einem gehege patria ich freue mich mal
eben kurz sagen ich hätte dich jetzt
komme aber wieder ist viele wie die
rettungsaktion weiter geht seht ihr dann
gomez folgen könnt ihr mal sehen wie
viele sind ja und warte ja ich muss die
folgen seien hier beenden ich habe ja
auch schon wieder gold gefunden und
kohle also ein guter freund hier auf
jeden fall und da komme ich das gold
fällt runter rasen direkt der nächste
coup alter zum glück hab ich im wasser
aber mit genau ich hab aber nicht mehr
so viel zu essen
oh mein gott jetzt richtig spannend
freunde wenn ihr wissen wollt wie
weitergeht gibt der folge ein daumen
hoch und schaut morgen komme vorbei und
dann will ich sagen tschüss haut rein
und schön mit